good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-1879
object class ketter
special containment procedures due to
the nature of the anomaly
scp-1879 cannot be contained by the
foundation
at this time foundation agents are to
monitor police reports within the state
of washington for
signs of possible scp-1879
when an instance of scp-1879-1 is found
mobile task force row 4 also known as
shoes salesmen are to be dispatched to
the location to deal with scp-1879-1
at the minimum possible cost to those
involved
all items obtained from these
interactions are to be incinerated if
feasible
and dismantled if not civilians that
come into contact with a cp 1879-2
are to be administered class a amnestics
after foundation questioning
description scp-1879 is a phenomenon
that affects houses
in the state of washington usa it has
been noted to
only affect interior doors which are
hereby designated scp-1879-1
these doors are visually unchanged
however
when a sapient organism comes within two
meters of an scp-1879-1
instance repeated knocking emanates from
the object
this continues indefinitely until a
subject opens the door
at this point a male humanoid entity
hereby designated as
scp-1879-2 will emerge from the
scp-1879-1
instance the entity is approximately 1.7
meters in height
and appears to be of caucasian descent
and indeterminate age
after emerging from the door scp-1879-2
will attempt to sell a product
to the subject these products appear to
vary wildly in purpose and origin
as the entity has presented a variety of
objects the entity will dramatically
explain the purpose and appeal of the
product
to the subject often cornering the men
suggesting they sit down before doing so
the explanations and tactics utilized
are often not
particularly persuasive and the entity
uses
underhanded methods to sell its product
after fully explaining the
entity will then offer a price said
price rarely consists of currency
and is often detrimental to the subject
or the subject's health
the entity consistently refuses to
elaborate or
comment on the definition of its prices
unless it decides to raise them
which it often does if the product is
not accepted and paid for
quickly scp-1879-2 is persistent in its
efforts
and refuses to leave the subject alone
until the product is purchased
however if it is sufficiently threatened
or wounded the entity will temporarily
retreat back into scp-1879-1
which will then revert back into a
non-anomalous door it will later return
within the same house via a different
door and confront the subject
attempting more aggressively or even
threatening them to purchase their
product
as well as increasing the price once the
product is purchased the entity will
thank the subject
and exit the area through an scp-1879
instance retrieval log 1879
row the following log is a short list of
items obtained from deals with
scp-1879-2
along with the described price and the
results
object received one red rose price
statement
all i'm asking for is your heart results
subject expired due to the
demanifestation of his cardiovascular
system
object received 220 bananas
price statement give me some sugar
sweetie
results all candied goods within the
house disappeared
object received one thermonuclear
explosive
price statement i want your soul results
subject hesitantly complied after
encouragement no notable effects
happened at the scene of the exchange
however the subject later discovered two
of her aretha franklin albums
ladies soul and almighty fire to be
missing
audio log 1879 eta
the following log was taken during the
initial attempts of foundation agents
to apprehend and discern the nature of
scp-1879-2
agent rogers was equipped with audio
recording devices
at the time of the event this incident
took place at
seattle washington the home of shirley
yates
mrs yates had previously called the
police several times urgently
describing a salesman that wouldn't get
out of her house
and kept disappearing into random doors
foundation agents intervened to
investigate the possible anomaly
upon arrival at the scene agents noted a
male humanoid entity
scp-1879-2 that was carrying a juvenile
border collie
and holding it in front of mrs yates
while speaking rapidly
playing log now
turning away from yates to address agent
rogers oh good maybe you'll listen to me
see i got this dog right but i can't
keep it so i thought
maybe surely like this i just popped
over and offered to give it to her
okay maybe not give per se a guy still
gotta get by right
anyways i offered it and that's not hold
on
before you say anything let me tell you
about this puppy he's a purebred and the
most playful little scamp he'll ever see
entity yells over his shoulder even if
he's apparently not good enough for some
people
if you don't listen i re entity holds up
dog to agent roger's face
just look at him he's so sad look he's
potty trained and everything
i just don't want to see him sad and i
really can't have him anymore
personal reasons you know really all i'm
asking for is some of your time you'll
barely even notice him around
cross my heart raising his voice would
you just some of your time is
all i'm entity is forced to the ground
by foundation agents who proceed to gag
the entity with a towel taken from the
house's kitchen
talking to fellow agents okay
we're taking him back to the site to
interrogate him agents attempted to
escort scp-1879-2
out of the house however upon exiting
the front doorway the entity
demanifested
agents were not able to locate it within
the house in the following investigation
of the house
scp-1879-2 later reportedly manifested
within the house
after approximately six hours and
foundation agents returned to the scene
speaking to mrs yates who was cowering
in a corner at the time
ma'am please he just needs a home i have
to sell him
it doesn't cost any money i promise just
12 years of your time
talking to fellow agents try to keep him
in the room this time
surely just take the dog and i'll be
gone
swear on my life mrs yates took the
animal
immediately she disappeared pleasure
doing business with you
the entity then walked into the closet
before agents get apprehended
after passing through the doorway
scp-1879-2
d-manifested class a amnestics were
administered to mrs yates family
end log audio log 1879
psy the following log was taken during a
successful foundation interception of an
scp-1879-1
activation event playing log
now rapid constant knocking sounds
emanating from scp-1879-1
god damn it hurry up i have to meet the
corner by tomorrow or else i'll have to
stay in this
world for the next century hey i know
you're there
spare a moment of your time
why does the boss even need this [ __ ]
anyways it's not like he has any use for
them anymore
a musical scale is heard emanating from
scp-1879-1
knocking ceases yes boss
i know i know i know that's not what you
meant by seoul i just thought you'd get
a kick out of
yes yes sir i will
yes i'm i'm sorry it won't happen again
please don't hurt it i'll meet the quota
this time i swear
yes okay thank you
goodbye sir
better get to move up to at least
accounting this time just get me out of
this
place already i've paid my dues and then
some knocking recommences until agent
rogers opens the door
hello mr oh you
hi hello no i'd like to ask
now see here let's think logically
you know i'm not gonna tell you anything
i know you're not likely to buy what i'm
selling so let's just move on to greener
pastures
i'm coming up close to a deadline and
i'm sure you're swamped with making sure
good people don't do their jobs
so i'll just be on my way and let you do
that
ciao entity attempts to close the door
agent rogers holds door open
and grabs scp-1879 too
that is not happening personnel retrieve
and detain
scp-1879-2 within the room
now are you going to talk to me
look i'm busy so i'll tell you what
i'm going to give you something no money
out of your pocket and we'll call it
even
sound good within one to three seconds
of this statement
approximately 2 000 coins of assorted
origin manifested within the pockets
epidermis and digestive tract of all
subjects at the scene
excluding scp-1879-2 all foundation
personnel involved were confirmed to be
deceased
scp-1879-2 was reportedly encountered
later that day
on a house further down on the same
street but had apparently demanifested
before foundation agents could reach the
scene
end lock this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
zargaran the morrigan
retalias karim el ashmuy
[Music]
revenant brian sanchez
sister hintern patrick bailey
matthew gilmore eric corbin
kawaii fire keeper longinus
carcass ethakwa king maring
james saba nj vojak
and oblong doucheboy
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash
thevogen thank you
you